corinne priest was walking home one
afternoon last november
when she realized a man was behind her
he
proceeded to follow me verbally abused
me
then he threatened me and harassed me
for about
what felt like a lifetime i don't want
any trouble
i don't want any trouble oh sorry
corinne had just got off the underground
in north london she was on the phone to
her mum
telling her she was unhappy to have seen
people on the tube who weren't wearing
face masks
she says a stranger in the station
overheard the conversation
and took offense and then followed her i
ain't threatening you yet but i've got
people here if you want to mouth off
like some
rude girl i was speaking to my mum on
the phone
corrin tried to explain her comments
were not aimed at him
but he didn't leave it's quite
intimidating is it i am an intimidating
person the world's my oyster i've got my
own hammer
i can do whatever i want yeah yeah you
can tell me what to do i'm a really nice
guy but when it comes to things like
that
petty comments like that oh you ruined
your friend to come and beat me up
easily do that right now curran told the
police she'd been harassed
and threatened i just feel that they
didn't take it very seriously it takes a
lot
for the victim to even go to the police
because you think to yourself
i'm no longer in any imminent danger i'm
not injured
the police told sky news there have been
no arrests and inquiries continue
these incidents all stem under the same
umbrella of male harassment
so the the most extreme
being murder and rape but also
catcalling wolf whistling layering being
stared at harassed
verbally abused sexual assault and so on
they all come under the same umbrella
corrin says she feels traumatized
whenever she watches the video
it leaves a scar and i now have a panic
alarm
which is part of my life now and that
brings me comfort
and i'm very vigilant and i
it's yeah you you see the world
differently
she thinks it's unlikely charges will
ever be brought in her case
but she hopes the anger and frustration
shared by so many women right now
will lead to meaningful change in the
way we as a society
view and deal with harassment becky
cottrell
sky news north london